[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast
[Music]
today
my name is brian clark i am the solo
developer for the first queries
this game looks interesting
tell us about the premise when we get
started
the basic idea is that you're a
newly hired politician
that ends up becoming deaf
so
the entire time you're spending the
night dealing with uh
you're trying to identify the names
we really take it as much very simple
yes yeah that was one of the things that
i really wanted to expand on after a
prototype was people really want to do
all right
oh
[Music]
so yeah this is rebecca and her
grandmother they're discussing the fact
that she is finishing her school and
about to pick up uh she's doing her
final review at riverfield mortuary to
become
nice
and she is this is the protection
what's happening in this sequence is uh
they're they're talking about the fact
that she is graduating and she's doing
her final review and her grandmother is
giving her this piece here which we
don't get background information on at
the time but it gets revealed through
various story events uh later on
i know something i'll tell you
this was cool
i just love the fact the premise is
you are literally a mortician like i
think that is awesome it's unique i
don't see that in gaming you know what
kind of thing so what kind of inspired
that look at this
well so i did a uh a game jam for myself
it's a self-induced one where i gave
myself a week to make a game
so i knew i needed to do a small
environment with a really tight gameplay
i wasn't sure what to do i realized that
uh dead bodies are three people yeah how
do i get you alone in a room with a dead
body
so that's where i was thinking about
either uh
autopsy or embalming
and uh and autopsy i felt was a little
too sterile about detecting yes and
embalming is more like a part where
you're getting it's i feel it's more
intimate and so i thought that was a
really good setting for it um but doing
that prototype uh it was really simple
about five minutes
you collect stuff and then you uh you
make a spooky thing happen that was it
but it gained a lot of traction and so i
knew that's what i did happened
saying that you need to sign this last
bit of paperwork for your onboarding so
we have
this let's see if i have uh
these prompts that come up to help guide
the player so there's the uh
quick inventory system because i access
everything in the inventory there's
regular inventory which is much
this part and then where i'm actually
teaching you the
demonic tendency stuff
and everything comes in the second half
after this tutorial
because i
i realized i was teaching people how to
evolve and i probably needed to get that
out of the way first
that's a good point
yeah it's a lot of extra stuff to do so
i wanted to make sure they knew what
they were doing uh going into the full
game
now we're getting into the
technicalities right now
we're getting them all lined up back in
do it do it right not pinky at all not
yet this is just a normal day in the
night
that's what we do what we do
i've got a little body wiggle
so uh now we're going to do
identifying body markings so we press
spacebar we bring up we see what we need
to do
so this is these are helpers for the
players first time to see what they're
going to inspect what you do is
manipulate body parts i can see there's
one right here
to interact with that and if i rotate i
can look on this side
and so i'll do that all over the body
here and try to find all the various
marks i need you can see there's a
number up in the corner here too helps
you keep track of how many i've got and
that's all identifying yeah so that's
the more gamey side of it to make sure
you
don't like find all of them and then are
left wondering if you've done it gotcha
but we really did not examination oh
just wait till we start you get pretty
close and personal wow
totally not making me uncomfortable
perfect that's right that's my whole aim
for the game to
all right so now that we've recorded our
marks we go into the recordkeeping
system
over here
so now i didn't want to do a bunch of
typing i didn't want people have to do
like basically i want to be able to use
a controller too so now what i'm doing
is a matching system
yeah this was this was one that i really
wanted to make sure i didn't do uh i
didn't do anything over the competition
it's got a nice
yeah like i was saying i really wanted
the player to understand how to do this
part
for us in the full game these are all in
their different storage spaces but for
the sake of the tutorial they're out
here
so first thing we have to do our
clipboard has changed so now we see
we've got to wire the jaw shut with the
needle injector
so we get the uh the needle injector
and the uh setting needles associated
with it
so now we're gonna come into here
he's gonna tell us how to do the setting
in the face
close that so what we do
so what we do is we now pull this up to
get it ready and then we click to hammer
it down okay
so we're going to do that a few times
until the barb is in there you can see
we've got a barb and a wire there now
so again totally comfortable
and now we twist it shut
and this is the actual process i put a
lot of effort into like researching all
this so it's happening thank you and i
look at like the department
i've actually been contacted by a lot of
morticians oddly enough but mainly just
the excitement that there's something
there's something in the field because
at the end of the day because they're
comfortable just baby a guy like me this
is the reality this is what people do on
a day-to-day thing so that aspect of the
game i know we're going to get into the
other aspect yep it's really cool that
you're doing it that's why i like it
because you make it space yeah i really
wanted something that had familiarity to
the actual process so uh when people
when is that actually how it's done they
could search it and yes that's actually
how it's
done yeah there's
there's stuff that i've like made
shorter or removed simply for time or
game design's sake
um
but
everything that's here is part of the
process
so now what we're going to do is we have
to cut into the carotid artery
which actually is located down here but
for the same gameplay it's up here
okay so now we've cut open and we'll
enter the artery forceps
now we have to get the tube that we're
going to use to uh
so we are all hooked up and we've got
our chemicals that we put in we got our
water line going through it so now we're
going to go ahead and drain the fluids
out
so during this process this is basically
everything's getting pushed through all
the vein system in the body and then
coming out the other end and getting
emptied out so actually this will
eventually turn clear
and we'll know that we're done
there's a sound cue as well but
visually i wanted to add something as
well so you can see it starting to turn
so now we've got a reservoir bag and
we're going to need the trokar so we'll
grab that too
and we're gonna go fill up our reservoir
bag
this is called a gravity filling because
you're using gravity to
run the liquid down into it so we're
gonna find a spot
now for the real thing you're doing a
lot more poking around in different
spots but for this gameplay this should
take the most sense
maybe maybe someday i'll go and add some
additional methods you can do that
all right so now we gotta mix uh some
cleaners
this is more gameplay related i want to
get the player moving around the
mortuary more
so they combine a deep scaler
and a cleaning agent
and now i've got
the actual tank cleaner here
oh this is unity
so this is all real-time lighting in
unity um which real-time lighting can be
a bit of a challenge performance
all right and we are live more
continuous
going to gaming.net and who is this fun
gentleman we have in the realm of tax
quest today i'm bartek i'm creative
director at clostridge the creator of
the last case of benedict
last week
this is one i had my eye on we saw it at
the xbox suitcase i believe and let's
just get right into it
um
one night left to solve the mystery of
his father's death
and to find a way
to detach from the demons
here
one life left to figure this whole thing
out
what we got going on so now we will
switch from the
real wall to what
we call the limbo
we now are in a in
what we call limbo
which is a distorted version of the
house it's
[Music]
already
because
in the real world benedict is like a
detective he uses his senses
to see to observe and so on
but the demon feels emotions so he's
like a detective here he can tell
benedict what he senses that the father
feared something or he wanted to hide
so we want to go really deeply
so
we are
we gathered
help you understand this
and we also reward the exploration
because we have two currencies one
rewarded for combat and one for
exploration the one for exploration we
used to buy and upgrade the item and the
switch back to the house
[Music]
oh
available
more mpcs to utilize yes
so we show that for now we show that uh
harry houdini who is our shopkeeper
and the
okay
a lot of colors
with some
very mature and intimate storytelling to
create a friction there
and this kind of naturally
makes us closer to for example kim
barton's work
[Music]
back and forth between the world i'm
gonna assume it's not an instantaneous
thing certain points that you can
initiate that app yeah at least uh
yeah
we unlock them
we call them anchor
and
from
so there are few mechanics that will
help with backtracking first of all once
you've gathered the
team from enemy
hp you will still do the same amount of
damage so you need to be cautious
but
later on you will be able to power
through the enemies that you once
defeated
you get your celery
go into the bars
[Applause]
again and again and i know we're in a
loud convention but i'm assuming because
do these fours have voids hacking yeah i
think they're fully formed
and
we
are very proud of
our actors and we think
it's one of
i didn't think the combat would be
something that i would be gravitating
like
i thought it would be more of a
narrative
but there is combat here oh yeah the
reason is
oh
let's go
try to use the clamp
at first it's more of a utility tool
but later on every ability
has also like a second tattoo on the
other hand that can enhance their
abilities so later on you will be able
to deal damage with the cells we can get
those from our friend at the top of the
water
uh
community i like that little trail
behind me oh yeah the
the companion
who knows what this means maybe in the
future maybe a future
oh
[Applause]
and things that maybe we didn't get a
chance to talk about that are in the
game
as possible so
for every
major part of the game the exploration
the combat and the puzzle we
will
create a separate slider and player will
be able to customize the experience for
the lighting so if you don't want the
combat but one of the hardest puzzles
you can get you can do it if you're
interested in exploration we can make it
harder for you
yeah so you give it a customization yeah
from causal action you put another style
with a player and the accessibility plan
you give it
for personal opposite maybe they want to
challenged themselves you can do that
too
oh pretty cool design so it's an
absolute pleasure the last piece of
benedict
xbox game yes xbox 35 day one
[Music]
welcome to the iron lords podcast